-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
While speaking to reporters
last week
about the ongoing investigation
into classified documents
found at his home,
President Biden defended
his handling of the files
that had been discovered and
said he has "no regrets."
Well, technically,
he didn't say it.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden's attorney
announced on Saturday
that FBI agents found six more
classified documents
during a search
of his Delaware home.
Oh, my God, how long
is this gonna go on?
I don't have that many
un-classified documents
in my house.
And how big is Biden's house?
Every day, there's a new update,
like, "Oops,
just found some
in the guest library."
[ Laughter ]
Also, you know they're onto you.
Why wouldn't you get everything
all gathered up?
When you were in college, and
the cops knocked on your door,
did you just flush
some of the weed?
[ Laughter ]
I don't get it.
Do all politicians do this?
Is that why Jimmy Carter
is still building houses?
[ Laughter ]
Just to store
all his classified documents?
[ Laughter ]
I think they're worried
I'm gonna do my Carter.
[ Laughter ]
Former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo's new memoir
is set to be released this week,
and just to save time,
the title of the book
is "80 Percent Off."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, don't look
in these new houses."
[ Laughter ]
The Senate was set to reconvene
this afternoon at 3:00
after a 20-day break because
nothing says
"Let's get down to business"
like starting work
at 3:00 on a Monday.
[ Laughter ]
Three men in California
were recently arrested
for attempting to rob
a cannabis dispensary
after they led police
on a high-speed chase
and crashed into a solar panel.
Man, that sounds
like you asked your grandpa
to make up a news story
about California.
[ Laughter ]
A horse in Australia
was recently spotted
in the back seat of a car
entering a McDonald's
drive-through,
but not leaving.
[ Laughter ]
So I can't tell.
Yea on that joke or neigh?
[ Laughter ]
Pretty good restraint.
Mike Scollins wrote that joke,
and we were very worried
that the burger was gonna have,
like, a mane.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Rhode Island
recently agreed
to a child's request
to DNA-test
leftover Christmas cookies
for evidence of Santa Claus.
And they're not gonna like
what they found out.
Uh-oh, looks like Santa
murdered a guy in '96.
[ Laughter ]
Public health officials
in Massachusetts
have discovered
a new strain of gonorrhea
that is resistant
to most antibiotics.
Massachusetts, where even the
gonorrhea likes to fight stuff.
[ Laughter ]
"You think you're better
than me, penicillin?"
[ Laughter ]
Finally, according to
the latest numbers,
"Avatar: The Way of Water"
has made $2 billion
at the global box office,
which is incredible.
Only $1 billion more
for the movie to break even.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.